ah look at this tomboy trihard just
docked think about it hi guys my name is
grace Helbig if you didn't know now you
know you should click subscribe to my
videos right now before you actually get
a complete taste for them and decide
that you hate them so click this button
right here it is October which means we
are inching closer to Halloween a
holiday that takes all of the jobs that
should be regarded for how hard the
people that do them work become regarded
for how sexy they can be I'm talking
nurses referees police schoolteachers
these are all very respectable jobs in
this present day 2015 if someone creates
a sexy Halloween version of your person
or occupation that should be so
flattering but a lot of us do want to go
the sexy route necessarily and a lot of
us don't spend a lot of money on our
Halloween costumes so once again I'm
gonna give you some really cheap
Halloween costume ideas last year I
showed you how to make a series of
Halloween costumes using one main
ingredient a cardboard box this year I'm
going to do the same thing but with a
different main ingredient this year I'm
using a paper bag now all those people
at Whole Foods and Trader Joe's that
judge you for not bringing a recyclable
cloth bags pack up your groceries can
eat [ __ ] because you are in fact
recycling these paper bags into a
Halloween costume that you think is
great and the rest of the world thinks
is pretty subpar let's get into these
Halloween costume ideas
and get you to the Shire Frodo no oh the
Hat I love the environment I'm very tall
in real life let's go to the future
let's go to the future again yeah there
you go there are some quick ideas for
how you can make a cheap easy clever
question bark Halloween costume using a
paper bag let me know if you have any
other ideas for paper bag Halloween
costumes and if you do any of these for
Halloween
god bless oh wait I got one more yeah it
worked it worked I don't know why can I
just hold them from the start oh ah 32
joke million tons of snapchat not worth
it